welcome laptop buyers let's get right to
it if you're looking for a laptop right
now especially for a student i have two
words for you
macbook air you cannot beat the
combination of speed endurance and
design especially for the 899 starting
price so that's it by macbook air thanks
for watching except she's not telling
the full story for some a windows laptop
is a necessity and let's face it 900
might be a little bit too much to spend
so what about the 3 000 other windows
laptops maybe you're looking for a
windows alternative to the air what pc
makers call ultrabooks
ultrabooks range from 850 to 1300
even the base models include a
touchscreen core i5 processor and a fast
solid-state drive
if you want a laptop that backflips into
a tablet go with this the lenovo yoga
pro 2. for a little more than a thousand
dollars you get a good track pad
keyboard solid build and a really high
resolution screen i also liked the super
thin acer aspire s7 the screen doesn't
flip like the yoga but it's got a great
display longer battery life and only
cost 950 at microsoft stores
and when you buy a laptop through
microsoft stores they come crapware free
which means not having to deal with
these
seriously if you ask me to update norton
one more time
but most people i hear from don't want
to spend more than 600 on a laptop
it's true in that range you'll sacrifice
build quality and some specs you'll be
looking at mainly core i3 or pentium
processors 4 gigs of ram and slower
spinning hard drives in that 600 range
the asus 13-inch vivo book impressed me
the most a best buy exclusive for
it has a core i5 processor a touch
screen and also a higher end looking
design than most other budget systems
i also liked the 399 dell inspiron 11.
though it has a weaker pentium processor
it still has a touch screen that flips
around and lasted longer on a charge
than the very similar hp pavilion 11. if
you dare tread into 350 in under
territory i strongly urge you to look at
a chromebook which doesn't run windows
but google's web-based os it's true
chromebooks are more limited than
windows machines but they tend to be
faster than the windows based
competition at the low end besides even
when i'm on windows i spend most of my
time in a chrome browser my top pick
right now for a chromebook is the 299
acer c720 if you need to stick with
windows asus and acer have 350 dollar
pcs that look and feel like old netbooks
they're cute but their track pads make
me want to cry and oof those screens so
let's summarize what we've learned here
today
for a higher end ultrabook check out the
lenovo yoga pro 2 which they should have
called the lenovo
for 600 go with the asus vivo book 13
from best buy and for 400 the dell
inspiron 11. and if you've only got 300.
the acer c720 is my chromebook pick of
the moment of course if you want the
best of the best go with that macbook
air now this is the real end of the
video
bye